foreign
[Music]
box today we're taking our first look at
the GeForce RTX 4060 nvidia's new 300
GPU which they say is 20 faster than the
RTX 3060 while the MSRP has been lowered
by 30 and Nvidia thinks that means they
have a winner on their hands but do they
well before we find out
today's sponsor spot is brought to you
by antec and their performance won full
tower e80x case designed to support the
latest RTX 40 series graphics cards up
to 400 millimeters long the P1 is bigger
on the inside with loads of options for
top and front mounted radiators
including the ability to support dual
360 millimeter RADS simultaneously the
P1 comes with four pre-installed storm
T3 pwm fans with the ability to expand
fan support to additional six it also
includes a temperature display dual four
millimeter tempered glass side panels
Cable Management covers complete with
velcro straps for quick and easy Cable
Management so for more information
please check the link in the video
description
okay so let's quickly go over the specs
the RTX 4060 it's not a cut down version
of the ti in the sense that it doesn't
use the same silicon rather in videos
using the smaller ad 107 silicon which
measures just
158.7 millimeters squared and that's 21
smaller than the dye used by the RTX
3050 but 20 bigger than the older gp-108
die used by the awful GTX 1050 series of
course those previous dyes used an older
and much larger manufacturing process
but the point is
ad-107 is Tiny so I can't imagine it
costs all that much to produce the
problem with ad-107 is that it has all
the same issues that ad 106 had and
that's the die used by the ti model it's
just worse in almost every way as you'd
expect the core configuration has been
downgraded there's 29 fewer cores and
texture mapping units with the same 48
drops the cores are however clocked to
just three percent lower a negligible
difference there but because there are
less of them the L2 cache capacity has
been slashed by 25 now Nvidia claims
that the larger L2 cache of the Ada
Lovelace generation helps mitigate the
use of much narrower memory buses and
while it might help it really doesn't
help enough and as a result products
like the RTX 4060 TI have really
struggled at mid-tier resolutions such
as 1440p the RTX 4060 with its 128 bit
wide memory bus provides a memory
bandwidth of just 272 gigabytes per
second for accessing the 8 gigabytes of
gddr6 memory and on paper its memory
subsystem looks pretty pathetic sitting
next to the two and a half year old RTX
3060. in short the memory capacity
that's been reduced by four gigabytes
sorry 33 reduction the bus width has
also shrunk by 33 and this is a 24 drop
in memory bandwidth sure it has eight
times more L2 cache but that will only
get you so far as I'm sure we're about
to see
now for testing this EP used is the
ryzen 7 7800x3d which has been paired
with the gigabyte x670e auris Master
using 32 gigabytes of ddr5 6000 cl30
memory I have tested at 1080P 1440p and
4K though we will focus on the 1080P and
1440p data for this review as those are
more realistic use cases for this 8
gigabyte GPU okay let's get into it
starting with my personal favorite
fortnite we see that the RTX 4060 is
decent here with 108 FPS on average at
1080p to deliver 6700 XT light
performance it was also 20 faster than
the RX 7600 which is impressive and 21
faster than the RTX 3060 though it was
still 12 percent slower than the RTX
3060 TI which is and was about the only
previous generation Nvidia GPU worth
paying attention to the 1440p results
are a lot less impressive here the RTX
4060 was just 13 faster than the 7600
and 11 faster than the RTX 3060 which
was a massive 20 slower than the 3060 TI
next up we have Resident Evil 4 and the
results here are a lot less I'm not sure
the word is impressive they're less good
let's say yeah we'll go with that at
1080p the RTX 4060 is 23 faster than the
RX 7600 But the more troubling result
was the mere five percent win over the
6650 XT to only match the old RTX 3060
and then 1440p things only get worse now
it's just eight percent faster than the
RX 7600 with 70 FPS on average which is
very much 6650 XT light performance
making it 10 slower than the old RTX
3060 which is a truly embarrassing
result for NVIDIA
moving on to a plague Tower Requiem the
results here are abysmal firstly the RTX
4060 it's seen to be 15 slower than the
RX 7600 1080p which are 66 FPS on
average it was six percent faster than
the RTX 3060 so at least in this example
it was faster than the old GPU that it's
meant to be replacing if only just but
again things do get worse at the 1440p
resolution and this is a resolution that
we believe you're far more likely to be
targeting with a brand new 300 GPU here
it's 17 slow on the RX 7600 and a
massive 27 slower than the 3062i but
more embarrassing than any of those
margins is the two percent uplift it
offers over the RTX 3060. the f-122
results are very competitive between the
RTX 4060 and RX 7600 and this game does
enable Ray tracing with the ultra high
preset so although the RTX 4060 couldn't
shake the 7600 it was 24 faster than the
RTX 3060 though despite that it was
still 15 slower than the 3060 TI
then at 1440p the RX 7600 and RTX 4060
are neck and neck and again the new
GeForce GPU was 24 fast on the RTX 3060
but 16 slower than the 3060 TI
the RTX 4060 loses out to the 7600 in
cyberpunk 2077 at 1080p trailing by a 5
margin with 182 FPS on average it was
also just 12 faster than the RTX 3060
and 14 sold in the 3060 TI and then at
1440p the 7600 pulls well out in front
offering 15 more performance than the
RTX 4060. again the new GeForce GPU
wasn't a great deal fast in the RTX 3060
just nine percent faster in this example
the RTX 4060 did manage to Edge out the
7600 In Dying Light 2 at 1080p though
only by a seven percent margin still in
this example that did make it 24 faster
than the RTX 3060 which is certainly a
nice performance Improvement and
probably the best result we've seen so
far the RTX 460 managed to remain quite
strong at 1440p and while the margin
over the RTX 3060 was reduced it was
still 17 faster that said it was also
just six percent faster than the RX 7600
so a much less impressive comparison
there for the new RTX 4060
the 4060 also gets knocked off in a
Watchdogs Legion trailing the RX 7600 by
a few frames at 1080p still it was 22
faster than the RTX 3060 and just four
percent slower than the 3060 ti so a
good result there when compared to the
previous generation GeForce gpus but
disappointing when compared to the RX
now increasing the resolution to 1440p
still sees the 7600 and 4060 neck and
deck and overall the result is decent
but just a six percent win over the
cheaper 6650 XT seems like a bit of a
tough sell to me
moving on to Forza Horizon 5. it's more
of the same this time the RTX 4060 was
just six percent faster than the RX 7600
and just four percent faster than the
6650 XT so while that kind of sucks
compared to the past and present Radeon
competition it does pretty well relative
to the GeForce 30 series coming in just
five percent slower than the 3060 TI
and then at 1440p the RTX 4016 RX 7600
are neck and neck so again pretty
underwhelming given that we're looking
at 6600 XT 6650 XT light performance
the RTX 4060 again only just manages to
Edge out the 7600 this time in Warhammer
3 where it was four percent faster so
basically the same performance though it
was 16 faster than the RTX 3060 for what
that's worth and I have to imagine it's
not worth a lot then at 1440p the 4060
was just eight percent faster than the
7600 which isn't amazing given it costs
11 more and the 7600 already kind of
sucks it was also just 12 faster than
the old RTX 3060 which also sucked and
has been sucking more reliably than a
Dyson for years now so that's exciting
stuff
moving on we set the RTX 4060 did manage
not to suck in Spider-Man remastered
pumping at 149 FPS at 1080p to make it
21 faster than the RX 7600 and RTX 3060
though it was six percent slower than
the 3060 TI the 4060 does slap quite
considerably at 1440p but even so it's
still 11 faster than the RX 7600 which
is the break-even point when considering
pricing it was also 17 faster than the
RTX 3060 and 11 slower than the 3060 TI
the new 300 GeForce GPU is pretty sucky
in Hogwarts Legacy with just 63 FPS on
average at 1080p which is a massive
sorry I mean insignificant three percent
improvement over the old RTX 3060 it
also only managed to match the 6650 XT
and 7600 while it was 23 slower than the
3060 TI and of course it's even worse at
1440p now trailing the RX 7600 by an
eight percent margin and the 3060 two I
buy a whopping 27 margin but worst of
all is that it was just four percent
faster than the RTX 3060 with slightly
worse one percent low so great job there
Nvidia
at least the Halo infinite results at
1080p looked decent though as here the
RTX 4060 did manage to match the 6700 XT
and 3062i with 93 FPS on average making
it 15 faster than the 7600 and 21 faster
than the RTX 3060 but if we increase the
resolution to 1440p the RTX 4060 starts
to go backwards and now it's actually
slower than the RX 7600 though it's
still 15 faster than the RTX 3060
The Last of Us Part One still isn't that
kind to eight gigabyte gpus when using
the ultra quality settings though it is
doable at 1080p with slightly
compromised one percent low performance
still the RTX 4060 was no worse than the
other 8 gigabyte gpus tested here but
the RTX 3060 certainly delivered a
better experience there are admittedly
with just 55 FPS at average it'd
probably dial down the quality preset to
say high but with the RTX 3060 you could
still set the textures to Max
then if you want to break the RTX 4060
and all eight gigabyte gpus for that
matter just set the resolution to 1440p
and ignore upscaling again the RTX 3060
is perfectly playable here but I'm by no
means a fan of 40 FPS on average but I
know a lot of you single player gamers
are pretty cool with that
the second last game tested is Call Of
Duty Modern Warfare 2 and the RTX 4060
is very poor here though the results are
quite good relative to the previous
generation GeForce models such as the
RTX 3060 and 3060 TI but when compared
to the 6650 XT and in particular the
7600 the 4060 looks very weak then at
1440p we find the Radeon RX 7600s 17
faster than the RTX 4060 with the
GeForce GPU only able to match the old
6600 XT
and finally last up we have Hitman 3 and
hit the RTX 4060 is only able to match
the 7600 at 1080p with 109 FPS on
average making it 13 slower than the
3060 TI and just 15 faster than the RTX
3060 then we see that at 1440p it was
four percent slower than the RX 7600 so
basically the same performance there and
that meant just an 11 increase over the
old RTX 3060
the real advantage of the RTX 4060 has
over the RX 7600 is power consumption
lowering total system usage by up to 15
in our testing it's certainly not worlds
better but it's a good Improvement and
it's around a 20 reduction when compared
to the RTX 3060
okay so here's a look at the 15 game
average at 1080P and well what can you
say pretty bloody underwhelming to say
the least just 91 FPS overall makes it a
mere three percent faster than the
already very meh RX 7600 and just 15
faster than the RTX 3060 which isn't
exactly an exciting generational leap
after two and a half years possibly
worse though is the fact that the RTX
3062i is still 12 faster and I'd say
this is where the RTX 4060 would really
need to be in order to justify a 300
asking price with just eight gigabytes
of vram
but unbelievably it gets even worse at
1440p and when polling your feedback a
little over half of you said that if you
were to purchase a 300 RTX 4060 you'd be
doing so to game at 1440p and we feel
that that's very reasonable in fact Tim
Baylon and myself all find ourselves in
the 1440p camp in mid 2023 but here the
RTX 4060 is only able to match the RX
7600 and that's a really bad result
because it means both are only about as
fast as a 6650 XT and you'll see in a
moment why that's bad if you haven't
already worked it out this result also
means that the RTX 4060 is just nine
percent faster than the 360 at 1440p and
that is a laughably poor result
okay so here's a look at cost per frame
based on the favorable manufacturer's
suggested retail pricing data here the
RTX 4060 looks okay not great I'd say
just okay it costs 13 more per frame
when compared to the RX 7600 But I guess
you could say the improved power
efficiency and dlss3 frame generation
feature justifies that premium at least
they might for some Gamers primarily
those of you who play single player
games and aren't that sensitive to input
latency
so when compared to the RTX 3060 TI
we're only looking at a seven percent
reduction in cost per frame which is a
pretty weak generational Improvement to
say the least but of course this is all
based on MSRP so let's now step into
real world pricing and here it is the
reason why the RTX 4060 is ultimately a
huge waste of your time and mine
at a cost of 4.91 per frame based on our
review data the RTX 4060 is more costly
than existing RTX 3060 and 306 GTI stock
so for Less you can either purchase the
faster 3060 TI which was 21 faster in
our testing at 1440p all the slightly
slower RTX 3060 which has more vram but
really if you're on a tight budget what
you should do is purchase the 6600 XT
for around 230 dollars it's a 15
reduction in terms of cost per frame and
while you're still limited the same 8
gigabyte frame buffer it is a much
better value product now not only that
but really ideally you should have
already purchased a 6600 XT or 6650 XT
about a year ago if you wanted this
level of performance that way you could
have enjoyed an additional 12 months of
your investment and it's hard to put a
value figure on that but what it is is
worlds better than spending more for
basically the same performance with an
RTX 4060 a year later
all right so now that we've analyzed the
cost per frame I just had to show you
this marketing gold from Nvidia I'll
directly quote in video here at recent
Energy prices the average gamer playing
10 to 20 hours a week could save a
significant amount while having a vastly
superior gaming experience in Germany
for example a gamer playing 20 hours a
week could save up to 132 dollars in
energy costs over the course of four
years when upgrading from an RTX 3060 to
an RTX 4060 man they must really be
struggling to sell graphics cards at the
moment anyway if I understand this
correctly Nvidia saying if
european-based RTX 3060 owners spend 300
more to 40 60 for a 15 performance
increase at 1080p which they call vastly
Superior or a nine percent increase at
1440p it will possibly save them around
100 over the next four years on their
power bill assuming that they game for
at least 20 hours per week every awake
for the next 208 weeks in short what
Nvidia is saying is in order to save 100
you must spend three hundred dollars I
think this comes back to the more you
buy the more you save what I can't wait
to see is how the RTX 3060 and 4060
compare in two years time let alone four
years what an amazing investment
opportunity Nvidia has presented us with
here now just quickly before wrapping
things up here's a look at the operating
behavior of the MSI RTX 4060 Ventus 2x
graphics card that I use for testing
after an hour of gaming and an enclosed
case with a room temperature of 21
degrees the Ventus 2X or a peak hotspot
temperature of 85 degrees at a fan speed
of 1800 RPM so not exactly an amazing
result but this is a very small cheaply
made graphics card it has to be said and
it would seem that aibs aren't afforded
much wriggle room on their MSRP models
then finally the vrm components are also
left naked on the PCB though the power
stage is maxed out at 71 degrees so that
design Choice appears to be a bit of a
non-issue
well this is very familiar isn't it
another newly released current
generation GPU that is simply not worth
purchasing at the launch price in terms
of value of the RTX 4060 it's really no
better than the RX 7600
and depending on how much usefulness or
value you place on technology such as
frame generation this new GeForce GPU it
might even be worse value the RTX 4060
isn't as laughably bad as the 4060 TI
but it's still pretty bad and as I said
it's certainly not worth paying 300 us
for the limited 8 gigabyte vram buffer
is less of a sin at this price point but
it's still a hard pill to swallow given
the RTX 3060 offered 12 gigabytes you'd
think by now 12 gigabytes would be the
bare minimum at this price point with
eight gigabytes only reserved for the
most entry-level Parts but that's not
what AMD and Nvidia are trying to
achieve here and unless you guys make a
stand we're unlikely to see big memory
buffers on next-gen gpus either so make
sure you do your best to let Nvidia know
you're not going to stand for it and as
disappointing as the 8 gigabyte vram
buffer is the real issue with the new
4060 series is the 128 bit wide memory
bus and Nvidia did their best to confuse
Gamers with the release of 46 DTI by
claiming that the upgraded L2 cache
capacity of the Ada Lovelace
architecture made up for the narrower
memory bus while also strongly
suggesting that also address vram
concerns neither of which is entirely
true or true at all while I'm sure the
larger L2 cache helps with bandwidth it
certainly doesn't go anywhere near
solving the problems introduced when
heavily reducing memory bandwidth and we
saw this time and time again at 1440p
and what it absolutely doesn't help with
at all is addressing memory capacity
ignoring the fact that all data stored
in the L2 caches mirrored out into the
vram I'm really not sure why anyone
thought 24 to 32 megabytes of L2 could
somehow make up for gigabytes of missing
vram it just doesn't work that way and
there are absolutely going to be
playable scenarios where the RTX 3060
will deliver Superior image quality and
play better than the RTX 4060 and you're
almost certainly going to see a lot of
this in future game
on that note the ray tracing support of
the RTX 4060 it's virtually worthless
not only does it lack the required vram
capacity to enable rtfx but the GPU
power simply isn't there either and the
RTX 3060 it's really not powerful enough
to take advantage of rtfx either but you
know what it can take advantage of
larger texture packs generally speaking
if you have enough vram and enough
memory bandwidth to efficiently access
it stuff like textures will have little
to no impact on FPS performance so again
the RTX 3060 will deliver a superior
visual experience for future games and
all you'll have to do is enable the
medium quality preset and then max out
textures and you'll see a big visual
upgrade with no real performance hit
this is something we plan to explore and
demonstrate with future content so make
sure you are subscribed for that the RTX
4060 though it's really what we would
traditionally think of as a GTX 1650 or
GTX 1050 TI class product uh 100 to 150
GPU not a 300 GPU and you really only
have to take one look at the MSI Ventus
2x MSRP model that we were sent for
testing to understand this isn't what we
would typically consider a 300 graphics
card the entire cooler fan shroud fans
and heatsink weighs just 350 grams the
tiny backplate is made from plastic and
the PCB has fewer components than a
high-end fan controller it's really a
slap in the face to Gamers but it's not
msi's fault you can rest assure that
this will be par for the course when it
comes to MSRP RTX 4060s
so there you have it don't buy the RTX
4060 it is simply not worth it at the
current asking price the 300 MSRP we
believe the RX 7600 that should cost no
more than 230 dollars so given that I
think 250 would make this a great buy so
we'll wait for the RTX 4060 to get down
to 250 but until then I would just look
at previous generation options or
perhaps even the second hand market and
that is going to do it for this review
of the RTX 4060 let me know what you
think about this product in the comment
section below I'll be sure to read your
comments and if you'd like to become a
hardware box Community member we have
float plan or patreon signing up to
either one of those things will give you
access to our exclusive Discord server
where you can chat with Jim myself and
the rest of the awesome Hardware box
Community we do live streams for you
guys behind the scenes content and Q a
so check that out if you're interested
but if not that is perfectly fine and I
would like to thank you for watching
this video I'm your host Dave see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign